you look
fantastic and i see lots
of furry friends in the wall which is
perfect because it's our last day of pet
adoption week
so i'm going to tell you what i did last
night
is that okay all right i did one of my
favorite things in the world
i watched an episode of friday night
lights and
i ate a giant bowl of carbs and
can we just talk about friday night
lights because i know that i'm late to
the party here
i mean like a decade or so but oh my
gosh
it's so good i
love it i am hooked and we're like
parsing it out me and my friend robin we
loving it
so i guess last night what i could say
is i did
netflix and ciao because
i was saying that i netflixed and
chilled
only to find out that i didn't know what
i was talking about
yeah does anyone know what netflix and
chill really means
uh okay so listen when anyone who lived
in the 80s
chilling was relaxing does everyone
remember this
anyone yeah okay well now
it turns out that chilling is something
completely different
it's like when someone comes over and
you like
do anything but chill so here i've been
bragging like
netflix and chilled and chilling is not
the same thing anymore so
i'm gonna call it netflix and ciao
by the way is anyone binge watching
anything in the wall bffs
let's see oh rhonda from shreveport
louisiana
[Applause]
thank you we love you oh i love you guys
and may i
ask who your little lady is this is
hayley hayley
are you guys binge watching anything
right now
yes we are we have been bench watched uh
sister sister
the two twins tia and tamara she loves
that show i love that
90s and now she's loving it as well so
who's your favorite tia or tamara hmm
i like tia tia
you know what uh rhonda and hayley i
bond with you
on um two things um one
uh that you're watching old shows uh
like i am and two
that um nancy javon and fallon and i we
started flower films together
and when we made movies we always used
to say can mothers and daughters go see
this together
will it be appropriate for both of them
um
and so i'm really happy to see you guys
watching
content together um as this was sort of
my fantasy
to make movies and then also now as a
mother
to two daughters it is really nice you
know what's really fun too
we started watching gilmore girls my
daughters and i and i had never seen it
something to look forward to and then
you guys can netflix and shout
out yes we will because it's like
okay perfect ladies thank you so much
for joining us